why do you have so many millions of
people uninsured because the health
industry is a business if it's not
profitable they're not gonna do it
Mike Honda has seen some of the worst of
America but he's also risen to the
highest levels of power held in a
Japanese internment camp as an infant he
was elected to Congress in 2000 and
served for 16 years
Honda lost his re-election bid last
November and on his way out he was very
candid about some of the things Congress
gets wrong and how that looks to the
rest of the world they come here says
the wealthiest country in the world you
spend more money than we do the yet you
get less services is it money greed
business interests that are often
preventing these progressive policies
it's politics the politicians who
succumb to these kinds of rationale and
sometimes they doing it against their
very interest of their own people is
that a modern phenomenon is that a
product of the two-party system no it's
not okay it's not a product of two part
it's a product of politics you know and
influence that's the age-old conflict of
profit over people and speaking of
conflict Honda is particularly sensitive
to kids and conflict zones the last bill
he introduced in Congress was a proposal
to take in Syrian children fleeing the
war in their own country it's tailored
to say that families who elect to have
their children 3 to 10 be sent here or
orphans to be under our care is a
no-brainer in terms of vetting them for
national security that should be almost
come here Holloman and pass him through
the bill is called the Save the Children
Act and although Honda knew it wasn't
gonna pass in his final days on the hill
he's hoping progressives in the next
Congress will pick it up I don't really
like too much putting a villain for
message but it's an important message
and there's another message here
Honda thinks the resistance among both
the public and some of his colleagues to
letting Syrian refugees into the u.s.
actually speaks volumes about today's
America those individuals came out of
refugee programs as we reported last
night many Americans are angry this is
kind of a a damning criticism of our own
country and of our own citizenship I
guess one is most people don't pay
attention to what's going on to the
number of minutes that's we expose
people on TV and in the media I'd be
surprised if we have 30 seconds that we
ever mentioned children refugee orphans
in Syria we're the most powerful country
and we're acting as if we didn't know
away I can powerless but we don't have
to be party can act on our initiative in
our sense of charity our sense of
compassion that we have for four
youngsters and children that's what
happens when you have people running in
Congress who have forgot their immigrant
forgot their past but you certainly
don't seem like you have I can't let it
you yourself have a personal experience
that maybe many people don't have in a
personal level I mean does it factor
into your to your work
in fact yours in in that I know what
government can do that is bad that I
could set aside the rights and
constitutional rights of a whole group
of people in the name of national
security when the japanese-americans
thought for our apology from our
government and sought reparations la
people said ah won't happen again
nonsense
it can happen again because the
permission is still there what would you
like to see change very quickly the
Patriot Act it's a permission to set
aside everything to be able to invoke
national security as a reason for sent
inside individual citizens and and not
citizens to their rights to due process
we invoked national security only backed
in 1775 we invoked a security in 1942
when they sent me to camp under
executive order 9066
we just have to make sure that our moral
compass our our policy compasses the
Constitution and understand history and
what his history has done what we don't
pay attention do you think our
president-elect understands that I think
he's a smart guy I don't know whether
it's in his realm of experience but you
know I'm a school teacher I was believed
people could learn I was a very
diplomatic answer I know I want to give
him a little bit more time because you
know but like I said before have you
said that we have to prepare for the
worst
you